the man who fell to earth it's got naked
David Bowie
what else could you ask for
I'll be sticking with my usual short
summary instead of a full synopsis of
the film but if you want a more detailed
rundown of the story and plot then I
highly recommend brows held highs
musical review it's both incredibly
inventive and deeply entertaining and
was in part what spurred me to give my
own take on the film in summary the film
is about Thomas Jerome Newton who
stumbles out of the hills one day sells
some gold for cash hires a lawyer gets
some patents gets rich moves his company
to New Mexico meets a hotel clerk -
named Mary Lou and she introduces him to
sex television and booze he gets his
company to build a rocket reveals to
Mary Lou that he's an alien and gets
double-crossed by one of his employees
named Nathan Bryce Newton is detained by
the government held captive and drunk in
a luxury suite tested and tortured as
gun sex with Mary Lou is released from
captivity than meets Bryce at a cafe
where they share drunken profundities
and the film ends now what first
inspired me to do this episode was
actually the gun sex scene towards the
end there in the Browse held high
episode this bizarre scene was hamed up
for its joke potential because well it
is pretty insane
but that said it's also the lynchpin on
one of the running metaphors in the film
which is the relationship between
audience industry and artists I've
talked about this issue before in the
news head episode but here we have a
completely different take on the matter
the running metaphor compares creators
whether they be inventors or artists to
aliens in the film Newton is literally
an alien and is our metaphoric prototype
for an artist he invents fantastic
technology because he comes from a more
advanced civilization on another planet
and the government keeps an eye on him
because they're worried that his
company's giant leaps in technology will
destabilize the economy and social
balance problem with this corporation is
that it is technologically
overstimulated and the economic trouble
stems from that fact in the real world
artisan inventors drive society forward
with new ideas and technologies both of
which governments throughout the ages
have been quick to suppress or control
in the real world artisan inventors are
typically viewed as being something
other than normal people who write
stories must lead kind of interesting
lives too
I know I love you I can character in
this story not so much for the raw
mechanical talent required to make
something but rather for their unique
outlook on life in the world one of the
most common questions asked of any
artist is where do you get your ideas
from it's a question that belies a
deeper view of creativity and ideas is
something alien to normal human
operation like artists are headed out
into the hills with burlap sacks that
they bring home brimming with freshly
harvested ideas in reality creativity
stems from a different way of taking in
the stimuli of everyday life be it a
sensitivity to music or an awareness of
culture and passion in the film Newton
literally experiences a different
reality he can see x-rays and hears
things from a great distance away and
this brings us to the infamous scene gun
sex I said earlier that this is a
linchpin scene so let's see if we can
fold out why to do this I'm going to
describe the plot again but this time
I'm going to do it in terms of metaphor
the artist comes out into the world from
the background of conflict hearing and
seeing things that the rest of the world
is oblivious to he uses his history and
insight to produce products that attract
the attention of the established culture
and power structure let's call them his
label in his fame and fortune he gets
distracted from his goal by sex media
and substance abuse he tries to break
out of the cycle but is restrained by
his label who locked him in a gilded
cage and continued to coldly exploit him
for their own game to the point that
they burn his unique worldview out of
him he is left desperate but creatively
emptied to the point that even his worst
ideas his most passionate and
destructive ideas are impotent
he's now shooting blanks and having been
used up the label casually discards him
to an ignominious fate in the film the
gun sex scene is the lowest point Newton
is creatively spent in powerless to his
captors and his addictions
and that's what I see in the man who
fell to earth it's not a perfect film by
any means the editing is odd in places
even by mid 70 standards and the pacing
is slow but it's still well worth
watching if only because nowadays it'll
be a cold day in hell before Hollywood
make something like this instead of
transformers 5 return of the cash money
robots also in some ways the film's
flaws work in its favor there are
extended metaphors and themes but these
elements aren't nearly as pervasive as
they might be in a more structurally
sound film which in these kind of movies
typically leads to symbolism overload
the surrealist sides and non sequiturs
often don't make sense and while it may
not be intentional the result is a world
that's more complicated and haphazard
than most narrative worlds more chaotic
and more like the real world the
characters aren't always consistent but
that's their consistency they make
decisions based on flawed or poorly
thought-out rationale just like real
people do it's not amazing storytelling
but it is a great story next week
brace yourself we're going to look at
the worst kind of storytelling
unintelligible pretentious crap
never know
it's their life on Mars